-After signaling
that they were willing
to do anything possible
to sabotage
President Joe Biden's agenda,
Senate Republicans
are now supposedly upset
that Joe Biden
won't work with them.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Even as new reported coronavirus
infections are dropping,
things are still very bad
and will likely stay that way
for a while.
With new, more transmissible
variants identified,
at this point, it's a race
between the variants
and the vaccines
and, seeing as how
the last administration
left the vaccine rollout
in chaos,
with some getting tossed
in the garbage
and others missing altogether,
there's a lot of work to do.
I mean, the Trump administration
passed on the opportunity
to buy more vaccine
when they had it.
Such a simple solution,
and they just missed it.
If Trump ever tried
an escape room,
they'd just find a skeleton
slumped over the first clue.
"Jesus! He's only been
in there for an hour."
Seriously, what was their plan,
send everyone a tin of Altoids
filled with hydroxychloroquine,
wait for Redditors to drive up
Pfizer's stock price?
"Mr. President,
why did you short
a million dollars' worth
of Pfizer stock?"
[ As Trump ]
I'm waiting for those GameStop
nerds to drive up the price.
"But you're supposed to buy it,
not short it."
Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, quick.
Call my broker.
"Who's your broker?"
[ As Trump ]
Okay, I'm going to tell you,
but no judgment.
It's Rudy.
[ Laughter ]
I think he might be bad
at this, too.
I told him to short GameStop
and he showed up like this.
They don't sell those shorts.
He went out and had them made.
[ Laughter ]
Also, how does a lifesaving
vaccine just go missing?
If Trump were part
of an elite heist squad
that stole the Hope Diamond,
he'd immediately stuff it
in his pocket,
forget about it, and then
throw it in the toll basket
with the rest of his change.
[ As Trump ]
Alright, guys,
good news, bad news.
Bad news --
I lost the diamond.
Good news is I've decided
to get E-ZPass,
which I think is going to be
helpful for future heists.
Also bad news -- I think I threw
my driver's license
in with the diamond, so,
stay away from the
safe house, guys.
States have begging the federal
government for more vaccine,
which the Trump administration
just didn't provide,
but, now, just a week
into the Biden administration,
significant progress
has already been made.
-Big announcement from the
Biden administration today.
They say they have purchased
200 million
additional vaccine doses,
which will be delivered
over the summer,
providing the U.S.
with enough doses
to vaccinate a total
of 300 million Americans.
-Wait, so it was possible
to buy more vaccine
this whole time,
and Trump just didn't do it?
What else was he doing,
having his gloves tightened?
Was he working on his
Jerry Lewis impression?
-We're going to walk down to the
[ raises voice ] Capitol!
[ Laughter ]
-Real nice find, Baze.
I thought the one thing
Trump was good at
was buying things with money
that wasn't technically his.
I guess that explains
that famous passage
in "The Art of the Deal"...
Biden announced the plan
to buy more vaccine on Tuesday
and gave the American people
a rough timeline
of when they could expect
the doses to arrive.
-So today I'm directing
COVID-19 Response Coordinator
Jeff Zients, here,
to work with the Department
of Health and Human Services
and increase our total supply
of vaccine
for the American people.
That's 100 million
more doses of Pfizer
and 100 million more doses
of Moderna --
200 million more doses
than the federal government
had previously secured.
We expect these additional
200 million doses
to be delivered this summer.
-So the president
did a competent thing
to address the crisis,
announced it in clear
and simple terms
Americans could understand,
and he offered
a rough timetable,
so he could be held accountable,
and he did it
without barking at reporters
next to a worrying helicopter
about how some random celebrity
was nice to him in 1987
or whatever.
[ As Trump ]
Jack Nicklaus,
"The Golden Bear."
Never met a chip shot
he couldn't make.
Real son of a bitch.
Nasty guy.
Nice to me, though.
Heard they call him "The Bear"
because he [bleep] in the woods.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of people are saying it.
Look, Joe Biden is inevitably
going to make mistakes,
as all presidents do,
and there will be times
when we'll have to push him
on progressive priorities
and hold him accountable,
but with all that said,
it's just a relief
to have competent administration
of government again.
People just want things to work.
Instead, Republicans
intentionally wreck things,
so they can turn around and say,
"Look, government is bad.
We should cut it."
Ted Cruz basically says,
every day --
[ As Cruz ]
Do you really want a man like me
making decisions for you?
A man who, every morning,
puts glue on his face,
then walks to the nearest barber
and rubs his cheeks
in the clippings."
And, now, Republicans are eager
to let Trump off the hook
for inciting a violent mob
to overrun the Capitol
because he's popular
with GOP voters.
That's basically the point
Lindsey Graham tried to make
in an interview last night
on Fox News.
♪♪
-Here, now,
Senator Lindsey Graham.
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Was that a a pick, Lindsey,
or were you doing a last-minute
coronavirus test?
[ As Graham ]
Dang, I forgot my swab.
Good thing I was born
with ten of them.
Or maybe that was just
the last place left
he hadn't checked
for his conscience.
I mean, what were you going
to do with it, anyway, keep it?
[ Graham ]
When I find a good one,
I keep it as a pet.
This one's Bessie over here,
this one's Clyde,
and this one's
Braxton Beauregard
Bridgerton III.
He's my best friend.
Mama, when Daddy gets back,
I'm going to show him
my booger collection.
What?!
What do you mean,
he's not coming back?
Why?
Because of the
booger collection.
Well, I miss you, Daddy,
but I made my choice!
[ Laughter ]
I forgot why I was even going
to play that clip.
Oh, right.
The day before that, on Tuesday,
Lindsey Graham
had a bone to pick
if Democrats call witnesses
in the impeachment trial
and then threaten
to prolong the proceedings.
-If there's an effort
by the Democrats
to call a single witness
in the United States Senate
that had no record in the House,
there will be delay
of this trial.
There will be a Pandora's box
being opened.
We will want witnesses
and this thing will go on
for weeks, if not months.
-Oh, no, don't do that.
Witnesses? In a trial?
What's next, evidence?
Lindsey Graham is so bad
at threatening things,
I wouldn't be surprised
if he backed his way
into calling Trump to the stand.
[ As Graham ]
If Democrats insist
on calling witnesses,
we'll have no choice
but to call our own witnesses,
like Donald Trump himself.
How would they like that?
They'd love it?
Why?
Because he will most certainly
incriminate himself?
[ Laughing ]
Oh, Braxton Beauregard
Bridgerton III,
I have done it again!
Back in your menagerie!
[ Laughter ]
In fact, a thorough trial
that brings out all the evidence
would be a good thing!
It was a violent insurrection
to overthrow democracy,
the first time the Capitol's
been breached in 200 years.
Nearly 140 police officers
were injured during the riot.
And you guys, supposedly
the pro-police party
of law and order, want to just
move on and forget about it.
Every time anyone tries
to investigate Trump,
you react like parents trying
to wrap presents
in the basement
on Christmas morning.
Don't come down here!
Mommy and Daddy are
[ Mumbling ]
having sex!
"Jesus, Steve.
That just makes it worse."
I didn't know what to say.
I panicked.
But, should we?
"No!"
[ Laughter ]
Impeachment aside,
Republicans have pledged
to do everything possible
to stonewall and sabotage
Biden's agenda,
despite the fact
that 50 Senate Republicans
represent 41 million
fewer Americans
than the 50 Senate Democrats,
not to mention,
they lost the House
by a record margin in 2018
and their presidential
candidate lost
by over seven million votes
in 2020.
They just lost two seats
at the same time in Georgia,
a longtime red state.
And, yet, instead of reflecting
on how thoroughly they've been
rejected by voters, and why,
Republicans are actually
pretending to be upset
the Democrats
won't work with them.
"There's frustration
on the Republican side
that Biden, Chuck Schumer,
and Democrats appear headed
toward taking a one-party
approach to Covid relief."
Oh, I'm so sorry
you're frustrated.
I mean, my goodness,
we wouldn't want to upset
noted advocate of bipartisanship
Mitch McConnell,
who I'm sure is sitting
by a rain-soaked window,
silently staring
out into the distance,
wondering why no one across the
aisle will work with him,
only to remember that
he's a coldblooded assassin
who destroys all opposition
in his path,
and only then will he smile.
Seriously,
when you were in power,
you steamrolled Democrats
every chance you got --
you nuked the filibuster
for Supreme Court nominees,
you tried to ram through
a last-minute Obamacare repeal
without so much as a hearing,
and you literally
scribbled changes
into the margins of a massive
corporate tax cut
in the middle of the night,
like a drunk
writing his number
down on a bar napkin.
"Why don't you
call me sometime?"
Sir, you're talking
to the jukebox.
2020 was the worst year
for economic growth
since World War II.
Millions are unemployed,
losing their health insurance,
and falling into poverty,
as child hunger rises
to unprecedented levels.
It's the worst national
catastrophe in a century
and it requires
immediate action.
We don't have time to indulge
feigned victimhood
and wounded egos
of Republican senators.
Thankfully,
Democrats seem to understand
the urgency of the moment
and are moving quickly.
Today, Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
promised bold action and said
slimming down the COVID relief
package would be irresponsible.
And incoming
Senate Budget Committee
Chairman Bernie Sanders
had said he has no qualms
using budget reconciliation,
a method that requires
only 51 votes,
to pass a massive relief bill.
-Reconciliation,
which is a Senate rule,
was used by the Republicans
under Trump
to pass massive tax breaks
for the rich
and large corporations.
It was used as an attempt
to repeal
the Affordable Care Act.
And what we are saying is,
"You used it for that.
That's fine.
"You did it.
We're going to do it,
but we're going to do it
to protect ordinary people,
not just the rich
and the powerful."
Did I criticize Republicans?
Yeah, for using reconciliation
to give tax breaks
to billionaires,
to create a situation
where large,
profitable corporations
now pay zero
in federal income taxes.
Yes, I did criticize them
for that.
And, if they want
to criticize me
for helping to feed children
who are hungry,
or senior citizens
in this country
who are isolated and alone
and don't have enough food,
they can criticize me.
-Yeah, I have a feeling
GOP criticism
doesn't make much of a dent
in Bernie Sanders.
Bernie, you're going to wear
those mittens
to the inauguration?
[ As Sanders ]
You're damn right.
These mittens are warm.
And, when you freeze to death,
I'm going to wear these mittens
to your funeral.
I'm going to comfort your widow
with these mittens.
They're there, I'll say.
Now move!
Bernie knows how to harness
that Grandpa energy for good.
[ As Sanders ]
You had the remote all morning
and you used it
to watch cartoons.
That's fine,
but, now, it's my turn.
And I'm going to use it to watch
my cooking program on PBS,
called...
[ Laughter ]
This should be the message --
the days of complicated,
Rube Goldberg legislation,
where you provide tax incentives
for job retraining,
for workforce reentry subsidies,
or whatever the hell Democrats
used to talk about, are over.
Keep it simple
and make it sound good.
Do it like Republicans do it.
They'll write a bill
that makes food illegal
and call it
the Feed America bill.
Republicans use their time
in power
to dole out tax cuts
for the rich.
Democrats should use it
to feed children and the elderly
and then, they can pay for it
by taxing corporations,
billionaires,
and all the gold Lindsey Graham
digs up in his -- you know.
Massive, immediate relief
and large structural change
are required
to improve people's lives
and fix
our deeply broken system.
We don't have time to entertain
the bad faith of Republicans,
who obviously have no interest
in doing anything about it.
Democrats need to move fast
and ignore objections
from Republicans
intent on stonewalling.
Otherwise, negotiations
over the relief bill will...
-Go on for weeks, if not months.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.